it's only right to start with the
situation in ukraine uh as these russian
troops are retreating from the areas
around kiev we we've been confronted
with the true horrors
of what has happened
how do we respond
to what we're seeing yeah and i've been
speaking to uh my opposite number last
night uh alexander kubrickov who's the
infrastructure man uh minister in
ukraine he's in chief uh he was
describing uh some of those uh scenes
from his colleagues and the world uh
cannot just look the other way
and i think it's actually a terrible
wake-up call for the world both in terms
of uh what putin has done and human
rights and the suffering and also as
your previous interviewer was just
saying uh with the um the supply of
energy to uh the west which is largely
funding and continues to fund this war
effort so um horrendous our hearts are
with everybody uh involved they are in
very considering what's going on talking
to my ministerial opposite kubokov um he
is very very determined uh actually uh
wanted to speak to me last night about
the rebuild of their country when this
is all over so i think they believe and
are optimistic that they'll win this war
and push putin back
the thing that sort of strikes me is
that the only reason that we're actually
seeing
the full scale of what's happened is
because russia has been pushed out of
these areas there hasn't effectively
been time for
a cover-up um in the conversations that
you've been having
what have people been witnessing
i've um
unfortunately i've also been hearing it
firsthand um speaking to ukrainians as
well separately um and
it's it's quite clearly horrendous it's
harrowing in fact um we have family who
can come and live with us but their
their child was in a a uh
a bunker a shelter overnight for several
nights in in kiev and now when he's
playing he's talking about uh
and they're in relative safety right now
but he is
playing playing make-believe uh about
building bombshells and can you hear the
bombs outside my my bombshell and this
sort of thing so uh bomb shelter so you
know it's um it's a horrendous uh
picture and and of course we'll leave
many scars but i should say the
determination
from what i've seen of the ukrainian
people and their government to rebuild
the country i mean remarkably the
conversation last night was specifically
organized because he wanted to talk
about how they would get city design
back in to rebuild some of those
flattened cities that you've seen on the
television screens like maripole
and elsewhere and uh which is
extraordinary given the war is still
going on but such is their determination
to uh win this and push putin back and i
think they will
um just on the war crimes uh question of
course um do you need to see this do you
think that this all needs to go to the
icc
i think it's absolutely right that this
is all properly documented this matters
we've seen in uh in war before it
matters that this is documented
and that cases are capable of being
bring being brought
to uh international justice uh so i
think it's incredibly important almost
regardless what happens in the end that
the world notes uh and and frankly you
know
uh we we've seen this i'm afraid we've
seen this behavior from putin now um a
number of different times not just in
2014 in syria uh sorry in 2013 in syria
but in 2014 uh in in ukraine in crimea
uh and elsewhere so you know it is quite
clear that we we we must document this
uh the world must take note and i think
it is uh and i think it's very very
important that we continue to provide
awful some backing uh to the people of
ukraine not only the people of ukraine
but because the flight to ukraine is
roughly the same as flying to turkey or
you know greece it
it really is on our doorstep in europe
and we all know what uh what happens if
if putin doesn't stop there
what is the latest intelligence on the
actual military situation because it
feels like things are quite conflicted
russia reportedly withdrawing from some
areas refocusing on other areas we've
obviously had the explosions in the port
of odessa that have come overnight
is russia withdrawing or is it
regrouping
it's more complicated than uh
withdrawing um i mean it is a as ever
with war there's a lot of fog of war but
it's also um the case that this has been
a very disorganized uh campaign we all
saw the the 40 kilometer long uh um
vehicle uh into uh
that was trying to attack from the north
and then that broke apart
um we saw on day one
putin's forces tried to get to a
particular airfield to the northwest of
uh keeping now withdrawn from that
that's gone backwards and forwards lots
of times having said that you only have
to glance at a map
to see that not only does uh putin still
have the territory he'd already seized
illegally in 2014
but he's also expanded that around uh
donbass and is desperately trying to
link up his troops and indeed flattening
everywhere in between like americol
which has been largely uh wiped off the
the earth um so it's uh it's a mixed
picture i would say quite clearly not
gone to plan not gone to putin's plan
that is
and uh and and there is clearly some
some regrouping going on
but uh this is not over by any extent uh
and uh of course the ukrainians
should be able to decide their own
destiny it's not for an outside neighbor
to come in and tell them how they
reorganize their their country
completely unprovoked completely without
warrant attack on their country
let's look now shall we at what we can
actually do sanctions of course is one
part of the picture and you mentioned
there the sort of energy
side of this so the eu has spent 18
billion euros on russian oil and gas
since the 24th of february which is when
the war began the russian ruble has
perhaps unsurprisingly given that
recovered nearly all of the losses
incurred since that invasion started i
mean earlier this week you posted a
picture of yourself outside a
confiscated yacht i mean a few
confiscated yachts frankly are not going
to make any difference are they well
europe is bankrolling russia to the tune
of hundreds of millions of dollars every
day
well i think it is first of all it's
absolutely true we may come on to
discuss this the um the price of freedom
and defending democracy in this case and
doing the right thing it doesn't come
cost free i suspect we're going to about
to discuss the cost of living so there's
a flip side to doing all these things
and that is where
more so for europe who are
particularly in countries like germany
readily reliant on russian fuel have
been finding it very difficult to cut
off that fuel now we've said that in the
next nine months i guess eight months
now uh we will stop buying russian fuel
entirely uh none of our petrols from
russia about 18 of our diesel is and
there's some fuel that goes to other
purposes but we have a relatively low
reliance the problem for europe is the
very large amounts as you've just
described being purchased in russian
fuel uh they've said they'll try and cut
that by a third within a year
and all of it eventually it is very very
important we carry on down this route
because as you rightly say you can have
all the sanctions in the world and by
the way i think it is important to
sanction the oligarchs have been very
close to putin which is why i've been
taking uh not just the the the super
yachts that you mentioned but several
aircrafts including another aircraft
this morning um and freezing them but it
is also very very important that we're
not paying that cash into their system
because that money will go to fund a war
effort in ukraine and you describe the
devastation uh and the human suffering
uh in your opening so it's very very
important that we close that loop
britain is urging countries to go
further and faster on this and again i
hear this directly from
my ukrainian uh counterpart to the
british people he says where the brits
go uh they pioneer and the rest of the
world is following with regard to
providing help and support to ukraine
it's difficult isn't it because as you
say
the sanctions don't come cost free to
people in the uk and i think it's
important to say as well that a lot of
the costs of living issues
were here before the war began but it is
right to say that it's also exacerbated
it you know we're about to see the
biggest fall in livingston's records
began
400 000 more children being pushed into
poverty according to the resolution
foundation i mean these numbers are so
big it's actually hard to get your head
around them
given the fact we're committed to these
sanctions the chancellor is going to
have to come back with more help for
people who are on the red line isn't he
and this is genuinely the flip side of
uh both coming out of korean virus and
seeing the economy take off again
fastest growing economy in the g7 in
britain last year but also exacerbated
massively by these fuel price increases
which feed through to everything and so
yeah it's very very tough you only have
to look at the price of the pump or the
cost of heating a home and you see the
extent to which the prices have left up
and the chances so far has come forward
with a 22 billion pound uh budget that's
a that's billion not million 22 billion
package to try to assist people uh as we
go through this difficult um period
including 9.1 billion a bit which is
specific to the energy side of things we
absolutely want to look to do everything
we can
400 000 more children in poverty i
understand you can't fix everything but
is the chancellor going to have to come
back with more in your opinion
so so um
again i don't want to sort of um uh get
everyone lost in get us lost in numbers
here but poverty is divided into both
absolute and relative um positive and
sometimes uh the way it's presented uh
can uh be somewhat misleading to say the
least what we're trying to do though is
make sure that for example
if somebody is working on a minimum
wage for example 16 hours do you need to
come in at this point
because we're seeing 8.7
peak in inflation energy bills are going
up by an astronomical amount it is
absolutely correct to say that there are
many many families in the country up and
down many people watching this program
today who are going to be seriously
worried about how to feed their children
how to heat their homes in the winter my
question is
i'm not getting lost in numbers my
question is is the chance they're going
to have to come back and do more to help
these people because this is what people
want to know they're worried
so so first of all i do not mean to in
any way shape or form uh underplay it
because you don't have to be an expert
you just look at the cost of living
as you mentioned the increase in
inflation um i think equation rpi rather
than cpi but nonetheless it's very
substantial and uh that's why the
chancellor's already come forward with
22 billion pounds and i want to just
pick up one figure which is for quoting
i apologize for quoting rpi rather than
just i'll be honest
i'm glad that you're saying that it's
fine that's very reassuring but for the
sake of the people who are very
concerned about how they're going to
feed their children and heat their homes
do you think the chancellor will come
back with more help
well as i said the track record is has
already come forward with a lot of help
including more help just last week no no
no no
sophia if i can just get to the end
there's one point i think be helpful for
viewers which is to say
the one thing which has been remarkable
because of the help that was given
during coronavirus is unemployment is
down to 3.9 vacancies are higher than
before coronavirus and more people are
in work than ever before and in the end
that is the way that we're going to most
put money in people's pockets whilst at
the same time making sure that people
will be able to earn all
many of these people are in work though
that's right paying national insurance
and many people are on universal credit
uh in work it's right to say
so as i said i don't want to in any way
shape or form minimize this because it's
it's a very very big serious problem and
you're right to say it's been a global
problem as is that inflation that we're
seeing everywhere throughout the world
however
i was going on before to say that for
somebody who is um on universal credit
because of the way that the chancellor
has amended tapers
it means that somebody would be left
with more money in their pockets and the
way that he's amended national insurance
also means that people will end up with
more money in their pocket and that
national insurance change is coming in
very shortly as well so uh we're trying
to do what we can you're asking if we'll
do more i want to i want to absolutely
be clear given the chancellor's record
i'm sure he'll always be looking what
else he can do uh he's already provided
billions and billions of pounds to try
to relieve the pressure and i accept
that we cannot do everything i'd love
for us to be able to absolutely
everything these are global pressures um
and one of the best things we can do is
make sure we have a vibrant economy with
very low unemployment
okay we'll be seeing the prime
minister's energy strategy next week uh
what will be in it to help people who
are worried about how to keep warm
it's really important that we we spread
the
variety of ways in which we create
energy in this country and indeed in the
world because we've seen what happens
when
somebody like putin gets hold of that
energy supply so next week in the in the
energy strategy we'll be looking for a
greater mix of different ways to produce
our energy
which do not rely on imported
hydrocarbons there's gas and oil and
side of things particularly from
russia so you might expect to see
more small nuclear reactors nuclear
power you might expect to see more
offshore wind power those i think would
be the things to look for more solar as
well
uh interesting that you're focusing
there on the nuclear and the offshore
wind and of course the issue with
nuclear is that even according to the
government's own impact assessment it
takes 13 to 17 years for electricity to
be generated by a new nuclear plant
do you think planning law should be
relaxed to allow more onshore wind farms
as well
well just on nuclear
modular reactors are
likely to be one of the important ways
forward and um you know we've already
produced modular reactors they already
exist in in subs uh submarines um so i
think there may be other technologies
which can be moved along um faster i i i
don't favor a vast increase in onshore
uh wind farms for pretty obvious reasons
they sit on the
the the the hills there and uh can uh
create something of an eyesore for
communities as well as actual problems
of noise as well um so i think for
reasons of environmental protection
the way to go with this is largely not
entirely but largely off sea uh i went
out to a uh to installation
off the northeast coast recently um and
it is incredibly impressive uh not
widely known but britain's got more uh
off sea offshore uh wind power than any
other country uh in the world and i
think we could do with expanding that
further still so just to sort of clarify
your understanding is that the an idea
of like a big increase in the number of
onshore wind farms that's effectively
off the table for now is it
well i'd urge you to wait for the energy
strategy later in the week but uh
my thinking is what you really want to
do is develop in other ways nuclear
we will have
offshore wind i don't think you want a
huge expansion of onshore uh when there
may be cases where it where it makes
sense but i think by and large we've
established this now that offshore works
very well and by the way it's providing
quite a lot of our electricity already
some in your party would say that the
target to reach net zero emissions by
2050 should be reconsidered uh in the
wake of the energy crisis that we see as
adita helm professor of energy policy at
oxford university he was recently an
advisor to the prime minister this week
saying that target is hopelessly
unrealistic
do you think that the government is
right to stand by net zero
i think i think in the end um you know
the world faces different threats right
now it's a putin putin from from the
east but you need to
yeah we need to know that actually there
are other threats which are going to
destroy us through
or make life very difficult and destroy
communities through weather change so we
do need to
tackle climate change uh and actually i
don't think these two things are
particularly incompatible it so happens
that reliance on hydrocarbons from
russia are part of what's causing the
global energy
price uh hike so it actually makes sense
to do a switch away from those things
and to things which are renewable so i
think over there you know we're talking
about 2050 here not tomorrow so i do
think it's still right to make sure that
we aggressively pursue that and
britain's got a huge lead in this as i
say we've got the biggest wind farms in
the world uh we're leading on a lot of
the different green technologies so for
us it's it's it's new jobs uh which is
very very welcome and great expertise
which we are uh in turn starting to
export
i think it's good business for britain
as well
okay i just got a couple of other uh
stories that i'd like to get your
response to um firstly the concert of mp
uh david warburton has had the whip
withdrawn after allegations that were
made against him in a report by the
sunday times now he said that he hasn't
been
contacted by the complaints authority
how are you responding to this
well the party has i think uh withdrawn
the weapon put this under uh the
investigation which needs to go through
his process i i don't have any sort of
um further knowledge of it other than
what i've read in the newspapers and
what the parties said um obviously any
allegations like this need to be taken
extremely carefully but all the facts
will need to be
brought out as well so until we get
there i don't think there's much more i
can hopefully add to it
do you have any concerns about the wider
culture in westminster
well i heard you ask the previous guest
that um
i have to say i i don't even know
whether this took place in um
westminster for me it's uh an office you
go in you do your job you're in the
chamber uh you get a bite to eat you
carry on with your with your work um
it's certainly not the boozy place that
it that it apparently once was uh many
years ago in my experience i imagine
unless you go and sort the you know seek
these things out and as i say perhaps
not in westminster itself i'm not sure
okay now there's one other thing that i
was keen to ask you about at this
morning and i think you touched on it
slightly earlier in the interview um i
understand you're taking in a family of
ukrainian
refugees um can you tell us a little bit
about the family that you're in contact
with and whether or not they've managed
to make it to the uk yet
yeah uh they are not here yet we're
hoping perhaps in the next week also
they will be uh it's a three generation
family so it's a mother um her mom who's
um 75 a her son who's uh six and their
dog who's called max uh and we're
looking forward to uh to welcome him
here uh we um they they've been um
getting ready to to to leave um and uh
we we're excited to to have them in our
home
what's been the reason for the delay in
getting them to your house
the mum was traveling on a um they they
they fled i mentioned about them being
in a bomb shelter for several nights and
they fled out a cave uh reached uh their
uh krakow right now in poland uh the mum
only has a national what they call a
national passport it's like an id card
not a um not not a full international
passport and so
she has to she has had to visit a visa
office whereas the others are able to
travel without the uh without having
traveled um to a visa office um and then
there was the complication of the pet
although i think we are keen to remove
those complications as well
because it looked like the dog may have
to might have at one point had to
quarantine for four months and i think
uh i think that removes the foot to
prevent that from happening so i mean
it is important they're very
understanding that you do need to know
who is coming to the country and it's
not beyond putin and his cronies to uh
deceive
brits by sending people to living in in
the uk
who may have
you know the wrong the wrong motivations
but uh it it does look to me like it's
coming to the towards the end of the
process and i think they're they're
looking at booking we hope within the
next week or so to join us
the whole family is very excited we're
looking forward to them um staying with
us it'll be a bit of a squeeze but we
will make it work and
um and we're
delighted to be able to do a do a small
a small thing here and quickly before i
have to let you go the latest figures
show that i think 32 000 people have
applied for a visa under the home's view
crohn's scheme only 4 700 have been
issued do you have an update on those
figures and are they actually good
enough yeah so i mean look i i think
we're going to see this um cranked up
fairly quickly just overall 29 100
people have received visas under both
the schemes not just the homes for
ukraine scheme so 29 000 people just
over uh i think we'll see the numbers
with the homes for ukraine that's where
families like mine are bringing in uh
ukrainian families to come and live with
us we found ours through facebook i
should say i don't know the family at
all uh and um and of course there are
some necessary checks before they before
they come over but i think we'll see
those numbers expand very quickly and
it's unlimited it's not capped so you
know and i tend to think of them not as
refugees but really as evacuees because
they want to go home
they want to return and rebuild their
country in the case of the family that
we're having uh the husband is um is
still in in in ukraine so very very keen
of course they they'll be to get back to
him as well
okay thank you very much for your time
this morning grant chapster thank you